okay mm-hmm can you guys hear me I think
you guys should be able to hear me I
know this is gonna start at 12 but I
decided to start at 11 I'm actually been
hanging out with some family later on
today and then probably hanging out with
a bunch of friends later on tonight so
I'm not gonna be up I'm not gonna I'm
gonna be up late so I'm not gonna be up
early enough to actually do comics and
coffee on Sunday so I figured what the
heck we do it today on on Saturday I
don't even know what day it is it's it's
crazy to think that we're almost halfway
through May right now like it's it's
nuts but I don't know what can you say
it's it's weird the way things go so um
I got a new let's move that cable okay I
got a new device this should be starting
here in a minute there we go okay it
didn't look like it was starting anyway
so so as you guys know I'm huge into
vaping and I got I got a new device I
got a new atomizer I got I got the what
is this mutation X is what I got and so
I was like you know what like I'm gonna
try this new device out here for the
first time on on this on our or comics
and coffee QA so where's my juice
service today I'm vaping a unicorn milk
by Cottonwood which is really good it's
like a strawberry milk flavor and by the
way I have my window open so you guys
might might hear some noises but I'm
currently listening to
um one of the things I used to do back
in the day is I used to no I'm not gonna
play I'm not gonna play on my guitar
back in the day one of the things I used
to do is I used to take the the Jim Dale
Harry Potter
books and I used to put music to him
which was fun it was really fun to do it
added a whole new dynamic to the story
like I put in pretty lights and like I'm
listening to the one about the Quidditch
World Cup right now so that one's got
like jay-z and it's really cool like
it's it's really fun but the pretty
lights I think is what really makes it
cool but I also I'm listening to at the
moment so alright so let's let's give
this a shot because this is my first
tinder so let's put this on let's put
this on 40 watts this is gonna be nuts
alright let's see how this thing tastes
alright 40 watts is way too high maybe I
don't have enough juice in here you
handle to got enough juice yeah alright
let's add a little more juice to this
this is a total fail alright let's add
some juice onto this let's drown this
thing in juice those of you guys who
vape like you guys know there's no worse
there's always the worst taste then like
that [ __ ] burn taste I'm looking at
my reaction of the video right now and
it's just like oh my god alright so
let's take this down from 40 watts
because that's like eight and a half
volts let's take this down to take down
to 33 watts
oh good god son Wow oh wow that's six
milligrams though okay all right you
know what we're doing we're changing the
name of this show to comics and vaping
because the hell with it why not
we're gonna change I want to sit I'm
looking I'm looking the video right now
I want to see my reaction Oh God Betty's
here bidding is here what's going on
Vinnie
all right yeah we're changing the name
to uh let's give Benny a call let's see
what Benny's doing
let's call vinegar comic store and
answer your phone Benny there he is
what's up man
I figured as much
this late nine o'clock in the morning
your time yeah it's weird man dude I
just got like this new like I just got
this new atomizer for my e-cigarette man
I was watching you play with it kill
yourself yeah that's exactly what I was
doing I was dying yeah I'm getting ready
to die on the live stream so do why not
do this okay so what's really like a qa4
for Robbin Benny oh really okay
why not good I mean like I've got to
work on man all right so I'm working on
the video about dark side I've got to do
that today
oh that's it you're tricking me to test
my knowledge at Dark Side of the Moon
no dude like it's
stall of the week see initiative and
sound pic of the work you see initially
I got my hands on the whole thing
initially I thought I could just like
explain dark side like here's the dark
side no dude I've got to go all the way
back to Jack Kirby's like New Gods run
and was it the fourth world and all that
stuff sound like okay guys here's what
Jack Kirby did when he went to DC yeah
and then they took it away and then and
then that's it and then it's gone so
it's like ah but um but yeah and then
there's gambit like I'm gonna do a video
about gambit yeah and then it's gonna
mean that's for the next few days or so
but I might as well man I mean it can't
hurt because I did Marvel for three
weeks see is this the opposite man like
I've been doing nothing but Marvel like
time runs out and all that stuff and
like the Marvel movie so I need to give
so give the DC guys some love I need to
show some love for the DC fans so anyway
so um I mean look at my evening and I
like ask any questions there's like like
like a hundred trouble here yeah it's
like uh can I turn
can I turn up Binney all right let's
turn up bitty there we go
let's make Benny louder I don't know I
mean it can't hurt see the problem is
you're not talking as loud as you
normally do I know you just woke up
exactly not even caffeinated yet like
normally you talk louder alright Rob
would you like me to speak up if you
close everyone get some coffee in your
system man I've got caffeine here this
is comics and coffee for me in the dude
I made the mistake of grabbing grabbing
some coffee they didn't have any
caffeine that's exactly my question so I
was like alright so I was like I mean I
bought it so I might as well just like
you know drink it but it's like I feel
like I'm drinking water with the taste
of coffee like coffee doesn't taste good
no coffee tastes amazing I love coffee
alcoholic my buddy's like let's go up
for beers I'm like why are we gonna get
one beer that does nothing and it tastes
like ass alright so people want to know
what's your favorite infinity stone like
what's what's our favorite infinity well
mines the reality stone like time why
it's times like a dick times like a dick
are you serious dude it's [ __ ] like
tortured price didn't swear I don't see
the
I'm not later not minutes it's it's okay
like it's okay to be a grown up that's
fine
cuz time messed with the Captain America
times olden seems to have a mind of its
own
yeah that's true I did screw with
Captain America he came back and took
him into the future which is weird like
I understand all right I don't
understand all that stuff like I get
that the current run of four is taking
place during the eight months like the a
months later time period like that eight
month gap like I get that's when like
the current run of four is going on and
I'm sure it'll pick up the Secret Wars
next week but I don't get it like I
don't I don't understand like where that
whole Captain America traveling through
time fits it like I still didn't
understand it like after I done the
whole I did the whole video on I looked
into it as best I could and I'm like I'm
like look guys I have no idea where the
stands at continuity like he goes
through time but if he goes fifty
thousand years in the future then how is
it the secret wars works out I mean and
then you have Ultron forever so I mean
the next just did that - do you read
x-men well I have the only waxman no I
haven't read memory so not the only like
the actual uncanny are there they had um
they had it ran through a candy an
all-new but they had a mutant who went
to the future and showed us that like
magic becomes sorcerer supreme and like
a whole bunch of crazy stuff really yeah
no that would be cool then uh knows the
whole thing I'm one of the mutants into
the future and basically try and ended
up living in the future for like 20
years and had a husband and a kid and
then eventually imagine he's like no you
got to go back and like it was a whole
big thing a really cool yeah that's true
chairs broken I'm trying to fix it
you're gonna fix it alright let's see
yeah Rob is the full podcast we did on
twitch online what's up buddy
oh yeah the one where he kept flaking
out I need to get that one well I got
one the one where's no no I thought
let's talk about that after the show
after the whole cube I was like the main
one didn't flake out wait we did fine
with that one no I uploaded the main one
already the one with coming to you now
okay yeah no we're not doing another one
yeah yeah no I don't think so if you
guys ask about the bonus ones if you
want to watch those you gotta follow us
on twitch chats the point yeah that's
exactly it
um alright whatever man
I'm tired of mourning it's a rough life
we should play Grand Theft Auto tonight
I used to do we should man like I've got
to do some laundry but I'm down with
that
i'ma probably hang on my stream it's
questions it will dress up like Captain
America cuz I think I think he's
costumes in I don't know all right Robin
Vinny what's your least favorite MCU
movie ah I reran three because it was an
Iron Man and we should have been Tony
Stark three I don't know I thought Thor
the dark world was kind of weak like I
was like I mean I don't I mean it seemed
like it was he was decent like I thought
it was it was decent enough but it
wasn't like the best of the movies but I
do agree I'm Anthony see I said I don't
watch Iron Man through the other day and
I ran three wasn't too terrible I mean
it was decent enough it didn't have Iron
Man I mean if I want to watch a movie
about people like learning to cope with
crap I'll watch like like Grammy Award
Grammy Grammys music like Emmy
award-winning movies and stuff like that
you know the ones that are like are all
about people coping with crap I when I
watch Iron Man why does he have any
blast things and lasers yeah sure okay
least favorite conversion story which
was last week it was it was week four
because it was the Golden Age ones yeah
I don't remember it was one of the ones
in there I did I do a whole video in
that week yeah mine was like all the
ones from last week let issues last week
or the week before the Golden Age I
don't know the week before it the ones
where it was like like week four or five
because week five was actually really
good I had a lot of issue twos know the
ones where it was uh was what was it all
new adventure or The Adventures of
Superman
stuff like that yes of the Golden Age
one yeah yeah the Golden Age was yeah I
didn't care about those okay I was like
I don't matter that doesn't matter to me
but I'm I haven't read the issue number
two yet I need to read the issue number
two did we get mission number two for
Superman from the silver it's pretty
good to have wraps up flashpoint in
Superman nice I wanted to get that issue
number two and go through that yeah it's
worth picking up even if you don't read
the rest of the convert as that ones
what's picking up yeah that's true um
okay so favor uh what do we think about
the most recent episode of flash and
arrow
like I thought they were pretty damn
amazing have you seen him have not seen
error I keep trying to watch it and
because yesterday the last two days
turned into World War Hulk has been
delayed for two weeks so like Friday
instead of one like Thursday and Friday
was just held me trying to get it out
and it kept rendering bed so I haven't
had a chance to watch every flash I did
that flash is really good yeah all right
people want you to be on camera
you got to work down without do you have
your camera on that's always here now
well it's not oh there it is okay cool
good morning Benny here they compete
with fast right now maybe like it amazes
me how how in-depth your hair gets why
here why what's why I buy here just it
does some crazy [ __ ] what I don't was
definitely hold on a second guys you
guys are gonna see it flake out for a
minute you should be doing comics and
coffee on the twitch every Sunday so you
should be doing well I thought about
that but I don't have the the stream oh
yeah I gotta get you the access to all
that stuff yeah we should be doing to
see part of our live show plan yes I
know I know
all right uh we'll see if that works
charge it my babe no you're not you
don't think my babes not legal in any
other any other state registry there we
go okay Oh block yeah no it'll come back
up here in a second um there we go
turn my camera on okay so people should
be able to see that right there if you
really want to you man play playstation
I mean you know ignore what the chat
says okay cool how can you that this is
hilarious seeing your first thing in the
morning why I just says I don't know if
this was gonna show up on the stream why
it's gonna kill me she woke me up
talking a Rob I heard you talking it
wasn't business is she really is she's
not gonna say that now it's all me now
they get to see me full-blown
oh and see now the things on there well
that sucks
now you're in the corner seeing yeah I
know I'm trying to get this crazy shot
you're trying to do a screen with woods
with this what you need to do the OBS
and you can pick up the two of them I
have I have OBS but I can't get it to
like to take
in the comic story in all right guys I
need to know do I do I compete with
Fausto my hair is like this when it's
this poofy see it won't show like yours
see it won't show the windows here we go
okay cool no no should we need to do is
nothing stays on there here's how you do
you know what you have to do is you have
to turn your you turn your camera off on
skype and then you know it's not that
like I'm trying to capture the this has
turned into a [ __ ] disaster
yeah well this is turning into just
talking okay you know what we're just
gonna go back to the way it was that's
what we're gonna do okay
video capture okay there we go so you
have to you have to do them separate
that I got alright we'll get this shift
sorted out okay anyway um yeah it's it's
[ __ ] being a pain in the ass man
[ __ ] OBS I don't like the newest
update of OBS cuz it doesn't work well
with Skype like the old OBS worked fine
it worked perfect but now this one just
flakes out all the time and it's the
pain in my eye like we had you
transitioning into a into a secret war
with you last week yeah we did oh well
no that was because apparently when I
installed my new version of Windows I
didn't download the drivers for Logitech
for it's actually a really good book you
really should read this which one the
inhumans special it's a cap - its fact
that's Captain America the new one
spider-man and a bunch of new Inhumans
really that's pretty cool
nice yeah definitely special that's why
you haven't seen it it's not like in any
run yeah just you yeah alright cool I
couldn't get it to work the other way
where's from a video settings explain um
no no so alright so here's the here's my
let's see let's go back up to questions
I saw what I look like so yeah
ok so thoughts on Secret Wars so far
like I know you didn't read it a review
video its to get worse than new that's
just it's just one issue it's awesome
yeah ok you know what actually I'll read
of stay what I said in that review ok
cuz I know you love so yours in my
opinion Secret Wars and converges right
now at this point in Secret Wars this
phase are the exact same thing yeah the
story's pretty much the same now don't
get me wrong I do say Secret Wars is
better and my argument
even though they're pretty much the same
war you know planets go at each other we
need to defend ourselves that kind of
thing yeah the reason I think Secret
Wars is better is convergence launched
with a bunch of characters that unless
you're following every run in DC you
wouldn't know yeah look while Secret
Wars launched with a bunch of characters
you're invested in even if you're not
reading marble yeah you know the
characters you know what's going on so
even if you have not read a single issue
up to Secret Wars and it's the same
concept
everyone's going into fighting you're
like you know we go to converges you're
like what Batman is this and that does
not a little a green lantern but we go
in to see cordial expire man no Captain
America no door no you know these guys
so well see that was that was kind of
the problem like Marvel said the
Sycamores number one would be a good
starting point but it's not because if
you if you were like hey I want to get
into spider-man and then the first thing
you see is I guess spider-man lives but
he's helping to save a city you know
you're kind of like okay I guess there
might be a kind of a cool place to go
but if you're a fan like if you were a
fan of like Luke Cage I don't know if
you were like I want to get started with
Marvel Comics with Luke Cage then you're
gonna turn to Secret Wars number one and
you're gonna find out Luke Cage dies and
so now there's no more Luke Cage so okay
I mean I think I think that what they
were doing is it makes it make sense to
do it to you I think they were just
pretty much gambling with their biggest
their biggest characters they were like
let's just have all the biggest people
survive like all the most popular ones
right now and then just go from there I
also really use that like everyone dies
but they don't die like it like it just
fades to white they oh they were on the
raft there somewhere that's true but the
indication is that they die I mean how I
mean if they live then how do they live
well my current assumption is no one
actually dies it just gets transported
to battle world well if that's the same
thing I thought I thought too but the
whole purpose of the raft was to have
those individuals survive like those
people who other that was Marvel saying
those people who are on the raft are the
only ones from the earth-616 universe
that survived everything else died maybe
we're not gonna know until issue - yeah
or if they all got squashed but and this
your number two is gonna be my
assumption is right now at least that's
what I'm thinking everyone is gonna get
transported the battle rules but the
raft crew and the raft crew is gonna be
like separated from everything because I
got a feeling that people get
transported the battleworld are going to
think that battle world is normal
hmm so the ones in the raft are gonna
know that this isn't right yeah that's
true
well even then like if you look at the
actual battleworld layout on marvel.com
you have like the main battle world and
then off to the side you've got the
remnants of six one six and the ultimate
universe in the inhumans yeah and that's
what I mean like I have a feeling that
if when you're on battle world you think
this is a normal way of life and that's
that like it's like an entire new
history kind of like one knew what the
House of M and everyone just assumed
that was the normal history line yeah
that's true
that would be that would be a really
good idea too like if they did that if
they took that idea and the like there's
like maybe a handful of people like okay
so if what you're saying is the ones
from 6-1-6 would be like Wolverine from
the House of M where as soon as they
wake up they're like this like
something's wrong if is that what you're
talking about yeah basically yeah so
like the life guys are gonna wake up me
like that would be cool let's see it'll
be interesting because I know Secret
Wars number two we're supposed to take
us on all the tour like a tour of all
the different sections of battle worlds
so I don't know exactly how they're
gonna be that but Secret Wars is monthly
isn't it like the Secret Wars itself I
see that's seeker was supposed to go
into September but it's it's like weekly
right now I wonder if they're gonna
change that we'll see my thought was
because it says it's gonna make me sick
it's gonna be done at the beginning of
July like right before San Diego
comic-con uh-huh
well see that what that was my question
like like Secret Wars the main circuit
war series is a six-part series which if
it's if the entire Secret Wars event
runs for six months it would make sense
that we would get sick of wars number
one like we got on Wednesday and then
we'll get all the tie ins over the
course of the next few weeks and there's
world war two lions and they're all like
what three four parts they're not to
like convergence yeah yeah
so I'm that's why I'm really kind of
excited the problem is there's gonna be
a lot of lols because if I mean if it's
a four part series it'll be four months
before any of the series finished or it
might not be I don't know I mean are
they gonna be like convergence to just
release all the number ones or are they
I mean I don't know how they're gonna do
that if it were nice to give DC flack
for that but I do a lot of people who
just bought them all just it's correct I
mean it can't hurt but uh but yeah I
don't know see it's that's that's why
I'm they're not they're not clear on how
they're doing it which is kind of
irritating I mean maybe it's a parts I
thought it was I thought it was six
parts I mean if it's a part it says it
on
one of eight two of eight oh it's one of
eight oh okay I thought I was one of six
yeah this is one of it oh okay we're
aware now but you know I remember saying
one of eight okay maybe it is a weekly
series I mean I definitely keep up
interest here's a problem you have is
people will show what anyone it but if
it ends long before the end of data
world then what's gonna happen
why because Tambor's when we get the new
actual line we'll remember it's split up
into into three sections like you've got
war zones you've got I Kevin you've got
what you've got one between you got a
second one then you've got battle world
as a third one which is like where I
think battle world takes form like
that's the new universe going forward I
think that's how they how they laid it
out but I Cameron roughed up my head
they've been vague in general I so it's
kind of all right um does the the Marvel
Cinematic Universe need the x-men and
mutants no I think it's doing just fine
I actually like tomorrow cinematic
universe where it's a like the superhero
medic pool is small and the problem I've
always had with the mutants in the
Inhumans is in the least in my opinion
that gives us far too many options in
far too many like deus ex machina as to
house them I got powers oh they're just
him you and I like what the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is doing now where
shield is scared of even a couple of
Inhumans see I agree with that like 100%
see it was funny because last week when
I was talking about that people were
talking about what my thoughts were with
the Inhumans of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and I said what people are
seeing right now in the comics with
uncanny Inhumans this was the x-men when
Chris Claremont took over it was like
okay well we have a handful of x-men
then Claremont took over he just made
x-men everywhere like everybody was an
x-man and you know everybody was a
mutant and you can just like explode and
that's what's happening with the
Inhumans is Marvel's using the
inhumanity event or they're using I'm
not the enemy
the the fallout from infinity where the
tears and bomb was detonated and they're
saying well now we have like a license
to make anybody an inhuman and they can
basically just be mutants the only
difference is I'll have to have some
kind of physical form that might be
different but now it's just an ability
to give any body powers so it's pretty
much the x-men all over again and I
think the downside with them when they
initially came out with the x-men was
they made so many people mutants to the
point where there were more mutants so
there were superheroes and the value of
being an x-man when
way like there was no point because
anytime anybody died they could just
replace them with a new one and it
didn't matter but I don't know it's
weird I mean uh right now the Omar well
and this is pretty much the reason why
were getting ready to ultimate universe
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is what
the ultimate universe was supposed to be
but the ultimate universe just turned
into a disaster so yes I mean I like to
I like what they're they started
introducing mutes and humans everywhere
I think what I think would ruin any bit
of what we've created with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe well see that's
alright now here's a question I would
ask and here's a question I'm gonna ask
you guys in the chat do you think that
Marvel is eventually gonna roll the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in the comic
book form into the comic book series
overall like that's my question I mean
are we going to see like Thor for like
is the earth 1999 whatever it is is that
going to be one of the universes on
battleworld
even if it's not right now will it be
eventually like that we my question and
I think I think we'll see that like I
means a theory that I've thought about
no one's brought up so haven't really
mentioned it but I wonder if when we're
done mixing the two universes it's gonna
be the Marvel Cinematic Universe that
will make sense I mean then basically
what it's going to be and that's that's
the end of that and that's kind of
because they're like oh it's gonna roll
up but it's gonna be a lot it's pretty
much gonna be the same but a few things
are gonna change and were gonna take the
best out of both universes but I really
wonder if that means that it's going to
be the Marvel Cinematic Universe yeah
that's true
which one thing that no one's thought
about could be the reason why they have
rotated out Captain America and Thor
because you really can't have these
long-running series and comic books that
moviegoers aren't able to follow but if
Thor does better in a movie many does in
the comics let's give them a different
Thor so it's very similar Thor stories
but it's not Odin's son the one that we
know that's true that would be a good
point and plus they can turn around they
can just say well because Falcon is
currently Captain America then Falcon
will become cash in America the modal
Cinematic Universe and they'll say see
now you guys follow the stories the two
of them well exactly well that's just it
in because everyone's got the theory
that I'm you know they're rotating about
the comic book so that it's set up so
that we can rotate them on the movies
eventually maybe not may
so that we can continue to the comic
books and it doesn't affect the movie
universe and that's why it's doing that
and instead what we're gonna get his
occasional cameos and what they'll do is
like in the next movie - but like follow
the adventures of Falcon in Captain
America and in the comics but follow the
adventures of Steve Rogers as the head
of whatever you know yeah and that makes
sense to me does it matter what would
you do if if in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we rotated out and there's no
more Captain America movies but Steve
Rogers is still there but he's just an
old man now and you can follow The
Adventures of Captain Falcon basically
in like in the comics that will make
perfect sense I could easily see that
happening
anything with the Thor situation Thor
becomes worthy again but hey
conveniently there's two hammers so the
Thor book is gonna convince in you with
Lady Thor while Odin's son Thor is gonna
continue in the movies yes and that and
and see here's a question would they
bring a female version of Thor into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because the
fact is guys and we all know this those
movies bring in like 62 like a hundred
million dollars yeah you know the entire
run of five years of Thor comic books
does not equal out that much money that
a Thor movie will get a get them know
why the hell doesn't matter if they put
them in a comic yeah that's exactly
right all right let's see is vision
going to replace Adam warlock and the
infinity film and the MCU I say yes I
think that Adam warlocks cocoon
appearing in the mono Cinematic Universe
and I've thought about this the more
that I've watched the movies the more I
watch them the more I think that with
the without a more like it was like a
nod like James Gunn said yes that's Adam
warlock cocoon but he's never said Adam
warlock will appear in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so I don't know I
mean I think the vision as we saw him in
the age of Ultron is basically Adam
warlock so I think what if he literally
is if he literally losing the mind gem
what if he literally is Adam warlock and
just that that's why he doesn't know
what he is he eventually changes
basically into Adam warlock
well but keep in mind like Adam or like
had the soul Jim not the mind Jim yeah
but now you come on we've got enough
slight tweets that that could vary
what changes around I mean that's true I
mean yeah I'm not saying that it would
have to stick with wreckless with larger
tweaks and had a more a lot getting sold
getting to mind you that's true that's
true but I mean it at that point if they
come out and they said well Adam warlock
has the mind that has a mind gem inside
of the soul Jam the only people who
would get mad or like really hardcore
Adam warlock fans and there's like 50 of
them in the world and so it wouldn't
really matter that much I mean I did
this never out of a really good point
just to kind of go back to what we said
earlier he's saying you know what are we
think about the x-men universe being
separated that would go in line with
them making the main universe the movie
universe
oh the x-men are in the movie universe
so they're not in our comic run anymore
that's true and that would be that'd be
kind of a cool idea which also may have
part of the reason why they worked out
this whole deal with spider-man and they
so hardcore did it but they don't seem
to care about x-men so much because
they've got a keep spider-man in the
main universe yeah okay um what do we
think about th ink from agents of shield
as the MCU magneto who whose team I have
no idea who that is
yeah I'm gonna look it up to tink
Jake how was this build
ji NK yeah I got nothing did you mean no
I want to say did you mean Tia Ching huh
it's got nothing so I got yeah I have no
idea who they're talking about
I mean I don't know like be more
specific in your question in terms of
who you're talking about the names
probably misspelled honestly yeah
alright what do you think the biggest
mistake is and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so far Marvel Cinematic
Universe so far uh how they portrayed
one of the one of the electron that's my
big eye I don't like how they portrayed
him because in the comics he's he's one
of the oh my he's like one of the world
ending villains and he got portrayed as
everybody's buddy tries to just trying
to just fix things
yeah see I don't see you ranted about
that like the whole time during the age
of Ultron discussion on Twitch
event and he ends the freaking world 90%
of the time yeah that's true I mean I
agree portrayed Ultron as Hayes Ultron
everyone show up and stop him
oh there's so much yang they're talking
about that one the Sun that's uh isn't
that the mother guy's mom yeah I guess I
don't know she's she's seen he's not
really to make neat oh I see her as more
of the blackboard my Medusa role right
now yeah see that see that was my
thought like all right here's here's a
really good question to ask because I've
really been thinking about this for the
last few weeks of agents of shield right
now the only indication that we have of
the Inhumans having any kind of society
is GM that's it like that the like
Skye's mom and so as far as we know
blackbolt Medusa they don't exist so so
here's a question
disguised mom know that Black Bolt and
Medusa exist and if she does is she
intentionally keeping their existence
secret or is there no Black Bolt a
Medusa I mean I know they cast Wendy
straight play black ball but I don't
know if they're if he's gonna be like
Black Bolt
as we know him I know I would under
president think it they do exist yeah I
think that the black ball Medusa thing
is the royal family yeah and there's
multiple times where the royal family
has been ousted and kicked out of you
know wherever the Inhumans are hanging
out at the moment so there's nothing to
say there's nothing that says that black
Boulton Medusa the royal family are
currently over at iliyan they're
currently ousted by the family these are
two different sections and divisions of
the Inhumans it could be anything I mean
the Inhumans are a lot more complicated
than the mutants are the beans are just
mutants the Inhumans have like this
entire like hair Archy structure yeah
that's true I mean it could be just Game
of Thrones [ __ ] yeah the people in
afterlife are the Starks and you know
the people they're the Starks there was
something landing what's it called
King's Landing things landing yeah yeah
yeah black ball to Medusa King's Landing
right now the Lannisters there the
Lannisters we have a red wedding
everyone
they're gonna stab everybody to death um
no I don't know see that that's that's
really kind of a cool thing to me I mean
the way they're doing it doing it slowly
is interesting but the problem that I
have is I think they're almost going too
slow like it's it's they've taken so
long to build all this up and people
like all I think most what most Marvel
fans want to know is do Black Bolt and
Medusa exist in this in this continuity
we don't even need to see him like it
would just be cool if she said like I
answer to people whose authority is
unquestioned in the inhuman community
and that's it that's all we need
yeah and we're saying okay cool Black
Bolt Medusa over there and that's it
that's all fans one they've never
implied there is anything above her but
they've also implied there isn't
anything there isn't anything above her
yeah I've never definitively said like
this is it yeah
yeah so I don't know I think it'd be
kind of I think it'd be kind of cool
okay so more questions let's scroll up
and ask more questions all right what do
you a I got over here this looks good
Rob what do you think of Phil Coulson
still being dead in the movies see I was
I just saw that one see it was yeah it
was it was funny to me because I think
that but there was like there was some
kind of a question that was asked I'm a
member who was on Twitter or what but
somebody had asked Chris Evans about the
role of Steve Rogers and Phil Coulson
being alive and I think he responded by
saying as far as Steve Rogers is
concerned of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Phil Coulson's dead and so none
of the Avengers know he's alive which is
kind of weird considering everything
that's been going on in the fact that
Coulson's name it's basically been
broadcast all over the world with like
shield hunting for him so it's kind of
hard to believe that they don't know
that he's alive but nonetheless they're
saying they don't know he's alive um I
don't know I mean the question is at
this point are they going to bring him
back to the movies like would they would
they introduce him again and if they did
then what I mean what would he be able
to do the problem with Phil Coulson in
the movies was that he was just like
like the comedic guy he was the guy who
was funny but he really couldn't
contribute a whole lot like him shooting
Loki was like the one thing that he did
they contributed to everything and that
was it and so it was like okay like
where do you go from there I mean you
can't I think it was the lead shield we
need a new funny man that's what we need
to replace him with whoa but we have
comic books I would have said
Hawkeye but they've made him like the
family yeah they know but remember we
have Nick Fury back so you have any
fears not funny Nick Fury's like do what
I say and if you don't the world's gonna
end I don't care well that's what I'm
saying like word is Phil Coulson fit in
like how does he fit into any of this I
mean you've got Maria Hill who's
probably gonna be the second-in-command
of Nick Fury now and she'll probably be
the one to take over during during a
civil war maybe Nick Fury well I don't
know how they're gonna bring them in if
they're even gonna bring them in at all
I mean it's it's weird like with with
Phil Coulson he's like this enigma I
think that agents of shield is like the
place for Phil Coulson I think we won't
see Phil Coulson in the movies anymore I
think we'll see Phil Coulson isolated to
agents of shield and agents of shield
we'll just tie into the events that are
going on the only exception to that will
be probably be during infinity war and
they'll probably be feeding like Intel
or something like that to the
superheroes but aside from that I don't
see I don't see him being like a bigger
character in the movies at all because I
don't just I just don't see how it would
work out I honestly if anything it'll
probably be one of those tie-in comic
books where they revealed the Avengers
no and that or it'll happen in the TV
show they reveal the Avengers no because
they don't need the Avengers to not know
anymore yeah but it's just story wise
where are they gonna reveal it what does
it matter because like exactly Coulson's
not coming back so yeah yeah um I do
want to comment one thing in there
because it's part of what we're doing as
far as the weekly poll goes um someone
else when we're gonna put up the age of
Ultron weekly pull discussion all the
additional discussions that happen over
on the weekly poll to it well yellow's
monster twitch is where we're hosting
all the weekly poll stuff will be
remaining up there they won't be coming
over to the channel so the only ones
they're gonna be reloaded guys are going
to be the weekly poll podcast I lined up
on Chuck Rob's Channel and I guess if
Rob actually does move comics coffee
he's probably gonna upload his own video
here too also so yeah probably but as
far as the additional stuff that's why
we have the twitch so if you want to
support us please go over to the twitch
right now it's it's if the eligible
Monster one just that's just how it
worked out with twitch it's a long story
but that's what it is right now but it
does support the entire weekly poll it
doesn't support just me it's a it's a
weekly poll thing so yeah pretty much um
okay so alright um why do they keep
asking what you're smoking like I don't
you tell them a thousand times over what
it is yeah it's it's it's
the e-cigarette is what it is it's not
like we'd like people think I'm smoking
weed on you yeah I'm gonna put my
youtube-channel in jeopardy possibly get
it shut down for a community violation
of the Terms of Service for smoking weed
no way that's crazy
okay um all right here's here's oh
really here's a really good one if you
could pick one superpower which one
would you pick and why invisibility you
can do the math you make yourself
invisible like all joking aside it be
invisibility or teleportation because
what I would want regardless of all the
powers in the world I would want ability
that what no one could mess with me I
could go invisible do whatever I wanted
I could teleport whoever I wanted those
are the two bilities that I would want
to do and I would totally abuse the hell
out I would steal like from like Fort
Knox I would take as much money as I
could I would then like teleport and
like kill somebody in a house and just
like go invisible and like take over the
biggest mansion in the world and let no
one ever know and when they came looking
for me teleport out like I have it all
worked out man I don't know if I knew
teleportation man I'm gonna be cool but
I probably choose I don't know I
probably choose shape-shifting and I
could be anybody in the world see the
problem that I think you would have
though if you chose to be a
shape-shifter is eventually you'd lose
your identity like you'd forget who you
are because you to shape-shift so many
lot yeah like that's well that's almost
what happened to mystique that's what
yeah that's what happens to a ton of
shapeshifters like shape-shifting her
face she wasn't sure what she actually
looked like anymore remember yeah she
had to get a picture so yeah yeah it was
weird
and I think flash had the guy who
Hannibal whatever who you forgot what it
looks like yeah that's true I was gonna
bring him up um worse though cause like
he had like a blank slate face at the
end all right um some people are saying
time so we're saying time manipulation I
mean I don't know something like
probability manipulation see I think the
problem being able to make it manipulate
time though is it takes the value out of
living like if you know what's gonna
happen
yeah then there's like no mystery yeah
no I agree with you now and plus you
would I don't know about you but I would
totally mess things up I'd be that guy
that teleported back in time and stuffed
in a bug and killed everyone
somehow oh yeah yeah I probably I just
accidentally teleport back the dinosaurs
are so much Jessica and fall over and
some like the the first man or something
okay um do we think Netflix or do we
think agents of shield we're starting
mentioning the Netflix series and
vice-versa
that's a good question I think they will
now what I think I think first of it was
the test run to see if they can go and
get away with a darker grittier
daredevil if it'll even do well on
Netflix I think with daredevil doing
well we're gonna get a lot more mentions
I personally think that's why they
weren't more directly linked to like
Luke Cage and iron fist because they
wanted it to be standalone if that's
what it became yeah which we know that's
not gonna be the case now because it was
a ridiculously huge it's everything so I
think I think we're gonna start here
I think Ages the shield they're gonna
get reports of some street-level
superheroes in a you know in Hell's
Kitchen and stuff like that so yeah I
think that makes sense like just in
general just really go we tried to
recruit this guy but he was like no yeah
okay if we could create one superhero to
tie into Marvel DC Universe who would we
make powers names etc so basically like
name a superhero Superman like no no
like create a super you have to create a
superhero yeah y-yeah on the fly man you
know when I was a kid I was like six
seven I created a superhero called the
wizard and he had a magical cape and
we're like he could do whatever you
wanted with the K basically he was
Stephen strange but he looked cooler so
oh well he could do anything he wanted
to and he had a cape I mean it's also
made a guy named snake man if you look
like a Mega Man bill and blood I mean I
think they'll be exciting like yeah they
have like a Mega Man villain in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe like cross
over well if we're gonna do that we
gotta do something like crazy like you
know like would man leave me man
okay so here's a good one do you think
convergence is still worth reading I did
I personally don't really think so I
mean it's decent but the problem that I
have with conversions is there's a lot
of stories that just don't resonate with
me because I never read those stories or
never really
read those characters when they were in
their prime I think the main story arc
is because they at this point they've
established enough of what everybody is
that you're not really confused about it
oh and I think the main storyline is
doing it right while it is getting
convoluted at times I'm getting I've
seen that complaint pop up if you're
following it it's not too bad I mean
there's a lot going on but it's just
it's just like super Wars a lot that
first issue had like I think every other
panel was a completely different plot
other than the life raft that kept her
going through the whole thing yeah oh
converted as the main story is good as
far as outside of that in the tie-ins
they don't tie into the main story so
it's just like I say in my weekly
reviews if you care about the character
yeah read it most of those things are
very true to the character most but if
you don't care about the character don't
go randomly pick up the infinity ink you
know like it's yeah you have no idea
what's going on and you won't care about
it
yeah that's true all right how long do
you do this for not really about an hour
so about 20 minutes I have left you can
bounce out any time you want - I just
want good I'm gonna meet my mind go make
a bagel real quick that's gonna make a
big woman alright um what character
would I choose for Marvel to make a
movie about The Punisher definitely if I
could give any character or standalone
film in the Marvel Cinematic Universe it
would be the Punisher like and I would
pick Tom Hardy because I don't if you
guys saw it but there's a picture
circulating around the internet of Tom
Hardy as the Punisher and he looks
amazing like he looks so badass he looks
like a cross between like Mick and Bruce
Willis from Sin City like he looks so
cool
like it's it's badass is annihilation
worth reading annihilation is worth
reading if you like the older stories
but just remember guys with secret more
starting now none of the old stuff
matters like none of that old stuff has
has any bear at least we don't think it
will I guess we'll have to wait and see
how secret Wars pans out but I mean once
once this one sigit Wars finishes and
none of the old stuff is really gonna
matter that much okay what do I think
spider-man's role will be in Civil War I
don't know yeah I know Tom Hardy said he
wants to but he thought it felt like he
was too short yeah I remember I've never
seen that I don't know what spider-man's
role will be in in
Civil War I think that spider-man in
Civil War will probably be it's it's
difficult to do because spider-man in
the Civil War Comics his big role was he
revealed his identity to give credence
to Tony Stark's claim that registering
with shield will keep you protected but
you don't have to worry about any kind
of recourse but as we know he was
basically attacked almost immediately
and so that really kind of shot that in
the dark but um like like Spider Man was
the swing vote like Spider Man was the
one character that could convince all
the other superheroes to get on board
with Tony Stark and so video because
they were like well if spider-man will
reveal his identity well I mean it must
be a solid thing and so they went along
with it and this by the spider-man
doesn't have that I mean I guess we can
reference the older movies but are the
other movies but you know those don't
directly tie into spider-man of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and we don't
really even know how spider-man is going
to appear in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are we going to get the
backstory of him or is moment it's gonna
say you guys know the backstory of Peter
Parker let's just jump into it I mean
are they going to have Peter Parker and
Sony and Marvel is just going to
reference the story from Sony in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we don't know
exactly how all that's going to go into
play out so it's really difficult to
tell I would say if anything the
spider-man is just going to be in there
as a character that's just fighting in
civil war i'ma go be spider-man so
you'll probably get more screen time and
you'll get more you know more speech or
I guess more lines than anybody else or
any of the other other smaller
characters he'll be right up there with
like Captain America and you know I'm
Tony Stark and so on but I don't know it
will be really difficult to it'll be
really difficult to figure out all right
um hey hey hey hey great bagel with
brown cinnamon and sugar cream cheese
and I got a I got a fruit smoothie you
gotta go for my morning healthy
breakfast cuz I gotta go to the gym in
an hour
man those cars man I've been doing Q I'm
even like I've literally than eaten
steak and eggs like I eat total looking
good there's my work I appreciate it man
I eat 12 ounces of steak in the morning
and then three eggs and then 12 ounces
of steak in the end like the evening and
three eggs or sometimes I'll just need
all six eggs in the morning and it's not
eat eggs for rest of the day it kind of
depends
well I kind of I kind of wonder if the
whole over-over eating red meats a big
thing so I rate ribbing like three or
four times a week and then I do like a
lot of protein shakes to make up for it
so yeah that's true and jam lots of
chicken so many questions coming in now
this is fine that's that's the crazy
thing about this is there's so many
questions I do this Sunday yeah but I'm
gonna be hanging out with a bunch of
friends tonight and so I'm gonna be up
too late to do it on Sunday bagel and
smoothie explain this is just a running
gag that'll never go on I don't
understand everybody wants everything
explained like like somebody will say
something like like hey like I went to
the grocery store and I got this no like
the grocery store explained well it's
wrong do me a favor and explain my
Galaxy Note 4 go your Galaxy Note 4 it's
a phone that is better than the iPhone
or the iPad or whatever it is so anyway
explained done and done
all right um why do you need so much
protein protein of the building blocks a
muscle man you'll never build muscle
feeling good enough protein all right
long story short when Rob and I both
started pretty much doing this full-time
then we both the group we should
probably go to the gym a lot more yes
true - yep um all right Spider Man and
Avengers will be like the Hulk Hulk had
to do two other films with different
actors already yet he fits into the
Avengers fine spider-man could work
better than you think I don't mean I
think spinal would work fine it's just I
think that there's spider-man's
significance and the Civil War comic was
like 40 years running like Marvel had 40
year for the continuity to say well
Peter Parker has never really
voluntarily revealed his identity and so
we're just gonna make that happen in
civil war and this might a my fans are
like holy [ __ ] you know that was a that
was a huge deal that doesn't exist in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I mean it's there's no history of
spider-man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and even if Marvel said okay
we're gonna bring in spider-man to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and we're
going to reference spider-man from the
Sony films to give you the backstory
that you need fans are still gonna be
like well I mean yeah he revealed his
identity but what's the importance of
that like what does that matter
well you got to think of this stuff I
don't know I know you
I'm assuming you answer this question
before I got here but everyone that's
currently out in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is not hiding their identity
everyone's known so what they're gonna
have to do is bring out a whole bunch of
supposed mystery hidden characters
they're probably mentioned daredevil you
know they talk about mention Black
Panther all of these characters who
actually don't have their identities
revealed because everyone knows who
Steve Rogers is and Tony Stark and
everyone knows all of them ant-man my
will probably be the first superhero who
actually has a secret identity
yeah in a movie that's true well yeah
and I mean Carol damn we should probably
go by the name Carol Danvers I mean you
got the girl even when she was Miss
Marvel she had like a two-cent like
there's a little itty-bitty mass she
wasn't hiding nothing you know that's
true she also had a little anybody
outfit to go with it or whatever I mean
I'm hoping they give her like a little
more like like she's not nearly as
uncouth because in the in the comics
like in the comics they don't really
hide it like yeah like Carol Danvers is
you know really Pro you know like
promiscuous basically and it's like okay
whatever like well they made a joke
about that one in the the latest Spider
Woman run where she was a governor
changed my costume she's a gear really
shoot cause you've been pointing at your
crotch for the last like 60 years you've
been wearing a thong for the last 60
years so whatever all right do we think
James Gunn will build up on Nova or the
Nova Corps that's a good question I
don't know I mean okay here's the
question if James Gunn were to give us
like Nova which version of Nova would he
give us would he give us Sam Alexander
or Richard Ryder I would say I'm telling
you right now it's gonna be Sam before
that but and I wanna hear what you
theory is but I want to say that first
because I want to hear theer and I'm
gonna dispute it well yeah the only
reason why I say Richard Ryder is
because Richard Ryder was the basis for
well no he wasn't the basis because semi
Alexander wasn't related to Richard
Ryder well no but he wants to a degree
because remember Richard Ryder came back
and he created the Nova Corps on earth
with a whole bunch of members of the
planet Earth and gave them Nova Corps
powers it doesn't matter though because
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe they're
gonna go with what is they known super
here in the know superheroes Sam
Alexander thanks to the cartoon so what
do you think will be a better movie that
will reach out to a larger demographic a
story about an old guy who becomes like
the cop of space or a young kid who gets
granted a bunch of power
and has to go learn how to use them and
that would be a big kicker it'd be a big
draw for teenagers if like Sam Alexander
is a teenage kid that gets all these
powers like exactly a lot of teenagers
okay that makes sense I'd go with that
I'd go it's I mean I'm not I'm not
really preferential towards either I
know a lot of comic book fans are like
Richard Rider he's the only no vote like
you know Sam Alexander sucks and I'm not
a big I'm not really like that Richard
Rider was cool but I like Sam Alexander
at the same time I mean Nova isn't like
a character that draws me in it's not
like oh my god a nova book I've got to
buy this it's not like that it's one of
the ones I it's one of those ones that
I've always intended to do in the
channel but like I can never find time
yeah I mean I you know it's I did
Richard Rider and I just did rich around
it for the sake of having done Richard
Rider I was like you know what we'll
just do that whatever okay so here's a
good one yeah Jeff saw I can't say his
name but he says Sam it was a man I
thought it would be the comic relief to
which is what what I think that and you
know thinking back to the Phil Coulson
discussion I think that's what he that's
what the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
kind of missing now we don't have the
jokey character anymore yeah we don't
have the guy who could have been we
turned him into a family man I'm still
not happy about that we don't have
anybody telling Captain America that
like he was watching him sleep and
that's what he told him in the movie
he's like I was watching you while you
were sleeping
oh it was weird um okay so who's your
least favorite superhero in Marvel and
DC Marvel or DC rather you go first
my mouth is full okay least favorite
superhero spider-man I do I do not like
spider-man I just don't like him at all
like all he does is complain and he's
not even that relevant anymore like it's
not written spider-man's not important
anymore like he was important back in
the day it was like oh my god teenagers
are cool in comic books but now it's
just like okay like he can swing from
buildings with his webs and like that's
it um I think spider is more relevant to
Mad Jim Jasper's but that's another
argument for another day no because
magic Jasper's could work reality man
Jim Jasper's was important because that
area in comics created the idea of the
multiverse in DC or in Marv
um well I think this is kind of a
two-fold question what superhero do I
hate and what superhero I think I'm kind
of tired of Wolverines the one I was
tired of I was started to popping up in
everything I loved Wolverine but there's
a kiss to a point was just like come on
bub would you just stop no yeah like I
was reading the latest miss Marvel trade
which is set before the death of
Wolverine and he pops up in that and I'm
like how God like I thought we were done
with this like yeah I am I am but like I
really really really was ready to see
him go you know it was like okay like
it's it's and it was it was funny
because even then like towards the end
like when they were thinking about
killing him off like even the Deadpool
comics were like dude it's time for you
to go like yeah it was it was it was as
far as ones that I hate though I don't
like Reed Richards because he never does
anything useful ever and his power is to
stretch and all she ever uses it for is
to reach down the end of a table
everything I've ever read about him he
never does anything useful well I've
never seen him in a proper light where
it makes me go I want to buy a Fantastic
Four book well the Fantastic Four
haven't been important in a long time
now I mean yeah they have it like I was
actually reading about like I was
reading this debate on on reddit then
somebody asked the question like do you
do you think the Fantastic Four is still
relevant so I was like well of course
they are it's like why there's like whoa
I mean you know reasons it's pretty much
with their argument amounted to separate
from the main Marvel Universe so like 15
years ever since Bendis to go over the
general direction he basically said I
don't like them and shuffle them to the
side yeah like it's just he's not that
is not that important anymore right now
I will say this I think Susan storm is
more interesting of a character now
especially after time runs out she was
more interesting of a character because
she was a spy and you know like the way
she was able to portray herself like
that was really cool but um I mean the
fact is like there and okay here's a
question that nobody's asked you and I
want to know this question from you guys
in the chat what do you think happened
to Susan Franklin and every like all the
members of the Fantastic Four
except for Reed Richards because I mean
like like you said like they vanished
into the end of like the whiteness but
it looked like they vanished into the
area between the convergence point like
they basically vanished into where
earth-616 in the Ultimate Universe were
crashing into each other maybe they put
Franklin Richards
place where he can just do the Franklin
Richards thing and just fix everything
at the end of this I don't know see
that's that I think is that's my
question I mean the problem that Marvel
had with Franklin Richards they could
never do anything with him I mean you've
got a character they can warp reality
okay you can't put them into any event
because then fans are gonna say well why
doesn't he just fix it you know you
can't have him do anything I mean they
established that you know before when
they said well he's basically just like
learning how to use his powers bait in a
basic form or even then he's not really
able to use his powers effectively that
was the big deal behind the Future
Foundation was at the end of it the Reed
Richards started training Franklin
Richards on how to use his powers
effectively like he teaches them how to
fly you know like that that is that was
like the big draw for Franklin Richards
he's finally becoming a superhero
finally becoming somebody that can use
his abilities but I don't know I mean if
Franklin Richards did save him
if Franklin Richards said okay I can
work reality there's a little bit of
reality here left for me to change for
me to screw around with you know
whatever and he saves them and then
takes them to this new battle world
then what happens I mean what happens
next and then where do you go with
Franklin Richards with winged leaders as
a whole that's that's the problem with
this character is he's there but he's
like a null entity he never does
anything and so what's the point of him
being there so I think if they killed
him off it was the right thing to do now
that now anybody except for Franklin I
loved like valaria Richards was a great
character I mean you know especially
during time runs out where she's the one
person that stands up and says look guys
you can't win like the only thing you
can do now like she went to dr. doom and
she was like doom you can't win like you
can't stop the incursians she went to
read and was like you can't stop the
incursions the only thing you can do is
just try to find a way to like survive
the collapse of the multiverse and so
then they started doing that like I'd
like her character been Grimm's a
classic character Johnny Storm Susan
storm whatever I'm kind of on the fence
with the about Reed he's just kind of
like man the most relevance he ever had
was during like the Council of Reed's
and that was really pretty much it so I
don't know I mean what about DC who do
you not like over there ooh I'm gonna
piss off a lot of people with my hands
I'd say right now we're gonna piss off a
lot of people okay I want to hear your
answer I'm gonna hear what's gonna piss
off - people you don't like that man I
love Batman but I hate Batman at the
same time because when Batman gets to be
Batman in the Batman book he's amazing I
love it when Scott Steiners run I love
to Grant Morrison run I love everything
demo Batman but the problem is Batman is
so important to DC that anytime he pops
up anywhere he's like I can fix all of
your problems I'm supposed to be just
the world's greatest detective but I
have everything in my bat belt and I can
fix all of your problems and I can go up
against Darkseid and it's it's cool
nothing nothing goes wrong they when he
gets pulled out of Batman he's just
beyond Opie character that should not be
open you mean every time he's pulled out
of Batman he suddenly turns into god
that's what he turns into and it's like
okay that's cool but that's not Batman
like they just do it because he's
popular I agree and in my the character
that I don't like and Marvel around
sorry in DC Comics is Superman because
Superman suffers from the same complex
as Franklin Richards what do you do with
the character who's just so ridiculously
powerful that only the most powerful
beings can stop him I mean we know that
like he that stays consistent so like
that's why he's all-powerful in his book
and he becomes all-powerful in other
books he becomes more powerful so he
gets more powerful enemies that stays
consistent but Batman's like he's normal
he's in the Batcave he's barely figuring
out how to stop the Joker but now he's
gonna go fight a new God like what yeah
I get that but I've with the exception
of Superman red Sun I've never read a
Superman's story that was captivate okay
I take that back the death of Superman
was interesting but have doomed or the
man of tomorrow or I'm these current
runs but ok Superman doomed was
interesting enough but Adam I I was
relatively interested in that I was more
interested with his interactions with
like at the scene where the point where
he's fighting Wonder Woman where one
woman shows up we're like she goes to
Batman it was like I need help and he's
like there's nothing you can do and so
she's like ok and then she goes like you
know I guess it was a flashback but
she's meeting with Superman and and like
he's oh he's officially like
dooms Superman and he's freaking out
he's attacking her losing his mind he's
I you should get out of here before I
kill you you know or something like that
and and so on that was
kind of interesting but aside from that
like I've never really read a story
about Superman that I found captivating
and the whole reason for that was
because yes Superman represents you know
the triumph of the greatness of humanity
and all that kind of stuff whatever
you've got a guy that can whole planets
and I'm expected to believe he would
waste his time stopping some woman who
are stopping some guy who just like
snatched a woman's purse
like what relevance would that be to a
person like Superman and that was that
was always my question you know why
would a person who was so ridiculously
powerful who could accomplish so much
who had no real rival with the exception
of like a handful of people worried
about such pointless things well I mean
no I mean
and I do great partly to an extent with
that Superman because the problem is
Superman is in every iteration they
always reset him he always becomes weak
again he becomes irrelevant like right
now in the new 52 I like him because
he's not overpowered but he's really
powerful so we deal with like normal
stuff but the problem with Superman is
that as time goes on they they keep
amping it up they keep making it more
and more powerful to the point where he
becomes like you just said what's the
point like if we just have a god
character but that's my issue with
Batman is he goes from being normal
everyday guy who's having problems
figuring on his own normal villains to
now he suddenly has to be godlike to
take out gods it's he in Batman Superman
Dilys days on that scale he gets more
powerful and it kind of a like I say
stays consistent oh like Superman got
his what solar bomb basically at this
point and okay cool he's getting more
and more powerful but it stays that way
like the latest Justice League run was
discussing his new power but Batman goes
from being I am now a god fighting sorry
God fighting against God's basically and
then he goes back to now I can barely
figure out where the two-face is hiding
I agree and and and I agree that Batman
does have his downsides but at the very
least I mean even though like Batman
still like a street-level character like
I could believe Batman would be stopping
a purse snatcher like I could believe
that Batman's trying to take down
organized crime in Gotham because he's
just a regular guy and that stuff could
affect him like organized crime could
make its way into Wayne industries and
that could cause problems for Bruce
Wayne you know just on the financial end
which would keep him from being able to
be Batman effective
with Superman Superman has no ties to
the planet Earth Superman doesn't need
the planet Earth Superman has like an
emotional tie I guess in the form of
Lois Lane but Superman has okay and his
family but Superman has no real ties
besides that if okay here's a question
Bruce Wayne has he has like his family
his parents are dead and he's got Oh God
I just forgot I forgot his butler's name
oh yeah Alfred Alfred yeah he's got yeah
that's not that's the second I was
getting ready to say like I was ready to
say Jarvis but now he's got Alfred and I
guess you could say he's got him Drake
and I guess you could say he's got
Damian Wayne but it's been made clear in
the comics that he's not nearly as close
to them as you would expect a father to
be with with a son or with like a
surrogate son or something like that
all right you could see a circumstance
whereby he would still be relatively
tied to the planet earth where he would
say this is my home like even then even
if you know even if I wasn't either if I
was out of those people whatever the
case may be
I can't just fly away I can't just go to
another planet all right Superman
if like Lois Lane died and you know with
with both his parents you know if if
it's ties to the planet Earth were gone
what reason would there be for him to
stay here there wouldn't be and so he
has no real tie to the planet Earth he
could leave any time he wants to you
know I mean there's there's no reason
for him to be here and that I think it's
like the downside to his character is
it's all just superficial stuff and so
it's like okay whatever but I don't know
so basically we do between us what if we
have to pick a character we dislike in
DC we dislike the two biggest guys the
two biggest guys
two most popular characters and what
we've mostly but we both are standings
we don't dislike the characters we just
like what they do with them yes
we just we dislike the basis behind two
of the most popular characters to ever
exist in the history of comic books
like the two characters who establish a
superhero archetype in comic books
stories in the channel I do Batman
stories I enjoyed where he's Batman yes
that makes sense okay do you think how
much they're getting better or worse I
think this was actually kind of an
interesting question I think better
because and everyone likes to say you
know classics are good
classes are good but classics the world
itself was different you couldn't get
away with half of what you're getting
with no stories were not as complex as
they are now you might not like what
they've done with a particular character
but the fact is I mean comics were so
wholesome that we had to go in the exact
opposite direction in the 90s and make
them super hardcore I think we have
found a nice middle ground where we're
not super hardcore
but we're also not like super super you
know family-friendly golden fun yeah and
I think it's contextual I think a lot of
people I think one of the one of the big
misconceptions it's like a lot of people
who were reading comic China at least
some of the younger people didn't read
like a lot of comics in the 90s because
they just weren't either old enough to
read or they just weren't alive at the
time and so I think a lot of people look
at you know the 1990s
you know Marvel Comics and they say yeah
now what a great time to read comic
books yeah yeah I mean now it was a
great time like you can look back and
say yeah it was a great time to read
comic books then back then it was kind
of like how it is now well it's like
well I mean there's really crappy
writers and there's really good writers
yep I mean it's you know like like huh
it's the same argument with like
nostalgia gaming and stuff like that the
old games well some of them have classic
storylines and stuff they're old and
crap in the game please jump compared to
what we can do nowadays yeah some of the
old games are you know oh yeah well
would focus more the gameplay now we're
doing more triple-a toys yeah whatever
but you have more options and more stuff
to do now you might not like the latest
your play title you have more options
the same thing can be said about comic
books you and this is my opinion
everyone who comes out because I got a
bunch of friends that are like Pokemon
Road is so much better than the new
Pokemon and I'm like no what's different
is what you were doing when you were
reading that comic book or playing that
game back in that era that's why the
nostalgia feels so good for you and for
a lot of us I don't know about you but
the 90s is when I was reading comic
books and I didn't have life to worry
about yeah exactly
wake up and go home I gotta do some work
and that was when I got to wake up and
go I'm going a complex tour to go pick
up spider-man 2099 yeah it feels that
the time period itself was better not
the books or their stories or the games
themselves yeah and I think that's
that's see that is the big catch like
that is that's the big difference see
okay
I'll talk about this all the time with
Call of Duty people say oh my god they
called you the community you know the
the
that's call of duty game ever and the
history of college ID was model fair to
know that era in Call of Duty history
was the best time ever advised everybody
was making YouTube channels on Call of
Duty and people were growing and it was
like that era was like this era of the
comic book community and some people
were like oh my god it was a bit no the
game had problems and the game will had
like some really bad issues it was that
point in time that was really really
exciting a really really fun so you know
it was new and you didn't have it shoved
down your throat a thousand times
originally our same argument you made
about Wow everyone likes ago vanilla
well was the greatest vanilla WoW was
the buggiest thing in the world
see I never played like I never played
world of work or decrease a date what I
was always had issues and problems and
lack of content but would but wouldn't
you were available to play Wow for 12
hours a day and had the world's greatest
guild and you felt accomplished in what
you were doing that was the greatest
time not what you were actually doing
yeah pretty much
like that is that's basically true
most people played Call of Duty with
modern warfare or black ops like that
was one day that was the game that yeah
there was once before that and it had
his own little core base but those are
the two games that brought everyone into
Call of Duty and that's why a lot of
people go that was the greatest college
oudy ever cuz that was the one that
hooked me you know that's true okay
here's a good one um are you going to
get Arkham Knight for your less pleasure
okay you know what is Arkham Knight that
one's not like two-player is it as a
game oh it is
dude we should definitely play arkham
knight when it comes out no I'm saying
what you're playing on played on twitch
you just gonna complain that it's not
marble the whole time no but um no I
finally got like GTA 5 downloaded and
installed on my um I want to test the
night we should definitely do that
yeah that's why tonight or tomorrow
again I gotta see cuz tonight am I go
see a movie there's a ex machina
whatever you know I've been debating
about going to see that movie like let
me know Howard let me know what you
think about it when you see it ya know
ya know it's only got one showing around
here so I gotta go like this very
specific time he's got one showing it's
the one showing it but it's got rate of
like over eighty on Metacritic so I'm
like oh really yeah
Wow well you're in front of injustice
comics is cool and I and for if you're
one of the people that has asked me a
thousand times I do in to my channel
we're planning it for June right now all
right who do you want to die in Civil
War everyone no everyone just reboot the
whole Marvel
that'd be hilarious that everybody just
died like they're all gonna die in
infinity war you know what here's the
kicker I don't think it's gonna be
anyone we care about I think it's gonna
be a Quicksilver it's gonna be someone I
totally like no don't stop talking real
quick about that but I think I see
someone that we get well I mean at this
point I think most like most people
don't care like I mean the last episode
of the week or Commerce and coffee was
spoiler free for age of Ultron so this
week we can have spoilers too much just
in case anyone didn't catch what I said
but I think someone's gonna have a
character they get introduced in Civil
War and then they're just gonna be gone
see that that's that's the question
because I think it's gonna be super here
that we started getting hyped up is
there and they're gonna be in the movie
like we don't even even know who they
are right now is just gonna be someone
see I'd like to see Hawkeye die in the
movie I mean they've established that
he's a family man that he's got a wife
and he's got kids and so on what would
happen if he died like how sad would
that be yeah I mean I don't think they
will because Hawkeye is an established
member of the Avengers and they're still
making books about it that's true but I
don't know I mean the books aren't
selling that well though so someone's
like Coulson Coulson will die it was
he'll die for reals this time for really
realest um all right guys we've been
doing this for about an hour or so so I
think right about southward a whole
bunch of pay attention to both of our
channels though because whatever we
decide to actually do the Grand Theft
Auto thing I will continue chatting with
you guys we'll announce it so yeah yeah
we'll definitely put up a video let you
guys know but um but yeah so um I guess
we'll go ahead and bounce off here this
was fun like you should you should be on
here more it's like early for me yeah I
know I know it's super early for you but
um but anyway yeah so I guess we'll
catch you guys later
thanks for having me Robin I'll see you
guys later oh don't forget about my
channel comic story